December is almost here Santa Claus will
be taking to the skies and he won't be
alone along with the reindeer doing all
the work pulling his sleigh the skies
are going to be crowded with spaceships
and balloons thanks to Amazon Prime
video for most movie fans Felicity Jones
is likely best remembered as the
reluctant hero jyn erso and 2016's wrote
one a Star Wars story on December 6th
she'll be taking a trip back to the 19th
century to become a pilot in the Amazon
original film the aeronauts Jones plays
daredevil pilot Amelia rent accompanied
by James glacier played by Eddie
Redmayne Wren takes to the sky via
balloon in hopes of making new
discoveries in the clouds the pair run
into trouble on one of their airborne
adventures and rather than discovering
new science they find themselves in a
fight to survive the arrow knots is
fiction but boasts some solid footing in
actual history while Rann is a purely
fictional character James glacier was a
real meteorologist working in the 19th
century based on the best-selling series
of novels by Daniel Abram and Ty Frank
the expanse premiered on Syfy it's a
critical and commercial success in 2015
the series follows a crew of anti heroes
who uncover a vast conspiracy during the
time when Humanity has colonized the
stars
unfortunately Syfy announced the
expanses 3rd season would be its last in
may 2000 18 thankfully for fans Amazon
Prime video stepped up to give the
acclaimed series a new home the show's
third season ended with the crew of the
rasa Dante travelling through the ring
gate to an entirely new region of space
all the surviving characters of the
previous season will be returning
but the expanse will have some new faces
as well lyndie Greenwood joins the cast
as dr. Elvin Okoye a UN scientist sent
to explore a new planet burn gorman will
appear as a Dolphus mercury a man who
wants to be the top dog in the new
planet and doesn't care what he has to
do to make that happen sometimes in Q&A
can it wind up on TV
Amazon Prime video is bringing plenty of
action flicks to the streaming service
in December including a couple that are
more than meets the eye when it comes to
its superhero fare prime video is going
outside the box as of December 1st
subscribers can watch 2008 s Hancock in
which Will Smith plays a deadbeat guy
with Superman like powers who has to
figure out how to be a genuine hero on
December 11th subscribers can watch 2018
s fast color starring Gugu and Botha raw
as
young homeless woman with emerging
powers she hasn't learned to control
don't expect this to be the last you see
a fast color on Amazon either in july
2019 it was announced Amazon Studios is
developing an original series based on
the film if you're eager for robot
action you'll be able to stream 2018 s
bumblebee starring Hailee Steinfeld
George Landon Berg jr. and wrestler John
Cena
on December 13 finally on December 30th
Amazon will stream 2011 s action-packed
Transformers Dark of the Moon if you
prefer your entertainment on the more
thrilling and terrifying side of things
Amazon Prime video has some new
offerings in December that might pique
your interest on December 1st you can
watch Denzel Washington as he tries to
solve a murder before he becomes the
prime suspect in 2003's out of time that
same day the service will also offer a
couple of corny 70s horror flicks that
insect lovers should adore there's 1974
space for featuring an army of sentient
ants waging war on a deserts human
inhabitants and don't forget 1975 s bug
in which California earthquakes
Unleashed footlong cockroaches on the
peaceful California city of Riverside on
the 9th watch Casey Affleck and
Elisabeth Moss struggled to survive a
dying world in the post-apocalyptic
thriller light of my life
on Christmas Day prime video begins
streaming 2018 s night hunter the
psychological thriller stars henry
cavill as weather detective Walter
Marshall tracking down a serial killer
that targets young women Ben Kingsley
also appears as a former judge turned
vigilante who's launching his own
investigations while Alexandria daddario
stars as criminal profiler Rachel chase
looking for a little drama on the first
of the month you can check out 2000's
almost famous which follows a teenager
who gets CAPTA to her with the fictional
rock band Stillwater and write about the
experience for Rolling Stone magazine
plus there's the 1987 John Hughes
classic some kind of wonderful after
that you can cut loose and show your
rebellious dancing side by watching the
1984 hit Footloose finally you can watch
Leonardo DiCaprio become the legendary
Howard Hughes in 2004's The Aviator
Amazon Prime video is a little light on
comedy offerings in December but it's
new arrivals include one impressive
standouts 1999's man on the moon the
biopic about the late Andy Kaufman is
named after the REM single man on the
moon which paid tribute to the
unorthodox comedian Jim Carrey plays
Kaufman
in a performance that saw him staying in
character for much of the film's
production both on and off set Kerry won
a Golden Globe for his efforts and the
film is largely regarded as the moment
any doubts that Kerry could excel as a
serious actor were dispel while the
actor made his bones playing absolutely
ridiculous characters like the lead of
the mask and the Ace Ventura pet
detective films Carrie made great
strides in the late 90s to broaden his
horizons his portrayal of a man who
doesn't know he's the subject of a
lifelong reality series in 1998 The
Truman Show convinced many moviegoers
Carrie could do more than straight
comedy and the man on the moon convinced
many of the stragglers check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]